Good morning, John.
You may have noticed, but I am not particularly
Hank shaped.
Hi, I’m Sabrina.
I just started university, so, as you may
have guessed, I am falling apart.
My love of naps and my hatred of myself has
made it so that the only thing that keeps
me warm at night is the dumpster fire that
is my life, because as it turns out,
it's really hard being a human being.
Everybody is stressed out by different things,
depending on their work, their relationships, their age.
I mean, babies are just out here trying not
to throw up on everything, and I—also that, too.
As a university student, I’ve got midterms,
presentations, essays, readings, and “suggested
problems,” but we both know what they mean
by “suggested.”
All right, I’m not saying that you gots
to do this, I am merely suggesting that you
do questions one to forty-four or else bad
things might happen.
That’s a weird accent.
And I won’t lie to you, I would probably
be crying myself to sleep if I was getting
some sleep, but are you ready for the big
plot twist revelation?
I am the happiest I have ever been in my entire
life.
I know it seems a bit paradoxical, but before
you call stockholm syndrome, consider the
possibility that we build this false dichotomy
around stress and happiness.
That happiness exists if and only if there
is no stress.
But I would argue that for most of my life,
the biggest hindrance to my happiness was
a lack of stress.
Good stress, not social anxiety or a crippling
fear of failure, no.
I am talking about the stress that comes along
with doing something that you love so desperately
that it fills up every hour of your day, and
sometimes even more.
It’s like when you only have fifteen minutes,
but the TV show you’re trying to watch is
thirty minutes long—it shouldn’t be possible,
but you always find a way.
Now, I didn’t have that sort of stress growing
up because I could afford to be so lazy.
Privilege!
But because of that, I never worked very hard.
I could never experience the fulfilment of
pushing yourself to your limit, of success
after spending so long at chipping away at
a challenge.
Granted, that challenge might be a course
where everything is just ¿Que?
And the midterm is tomorrow, but let me put
it this way: I remember sitting in my first
ever math lecture, taking my first step towards
a math major, and realizing I don’t know
how to do math.
I have made a horrible miscalculation, probably
because I don’t know how to do math.
And that realization should have destroyed
me.
My entire life plan is probably gonna fail,
just like me in math class.
But instead of collapsing into this little
stress singularity, I remember smiling.
Maybe it was just a coping mechanism, but
I like to think that it’s because I am so
enamored with knowing that there is so much
more to know.
And now here I am, arguably too aware that
I know nothing, but for the first time in
my life, I feel like I am working towards
something.
The factors that are stressing me out, the
readings and the writings, they’re the same
factors that build the framework for my happiness.
I can’t spend all of time feeling nostalgic
for hypothetical futures when I have a paper
due at 11:59 on a reading that I’m not even
sure that I read because I read at least 200
pages this week, and my eyes can only do this
so much before I accidentally hypnotize myself.
And when I do have free time, I spend what
I have left napping.
But what I have left after that, I spend truly
appreciating my life, my friends, and my family.
What I’m trying to say is that I am the
most stressed out I have ever been but the
happiest I could ever hope, and it is so good
to know that those things are not mutually exclusive.
And John, I’ll see you on Tuesday.